30 days to a better business so I got
this idea in the morning is having a
shower what if I created a free course
where i'd make a video every day with a
tip to help you guys as entrepreneurs
and then be available for an hour on
Twitter afterwards to answer the
question and to discuss and to help each
other out so say I'm making a video it
comes out at nine in the morning every
day you watch it and then from nine to
ten in that morning I'm there answering
questions on Twitter you can write to me
whatever you have will go through the
material on the video and help you in
that moment and give you something that
you can do today here is your task for
today to build your business free video
and me for an hour after the after
available on Twitter answering your
questions I don't know what you think
because I would love that when I was
starting out I would have loved that
resource an opportunity but I don't know
what you think because that's crazy work
for me and I'm not getting paid to do it
and I'm happy if it's going to have an
impact I'm happy to do it for you guys
but you need to want it so here's the
thing okay here's the test if I get a
hundred comments on this video from
people saying that they want it 100
comments for 30 days to a better
business with a tip every day and me for
an hour afterwards if a hundred comments
are on this video I'll do it for free
for you guys we don't get the comments
I'm not going to do it because you don't
care enough so let me know leave a
comment if you liked it enough and list
your friends we'll see what happens 30
days to a better business believe
you